B-Stall. Ein sehr gutes Abstiegsmanöver. Leider ein bisschen im Verruf geraten.
B-Stall. Wir ziehen alle B-Gurte und schieben den Schirm so über die B-Ebene zusammen.
Stollen den Schirm. Also er kommt von dem Vorwärtsflug in den Stall über und geht im sogenannten Sackflug dann nach unten.
Aber auch mit dem über die Spannweite geöffneten Schirm nur über die B-Ebene zusammengeschoben.
Wir haben ca. 7 m pro Sekunde sinken, was ziemlich gut ist.
Und das Tolle am B-Stall, ihr habt praktisch keine körperliche Belastung.
Es ist zwar ein bisschen streng am Anfang, aber nachher das Halten, das geht eigentlich recht gut.
Aber ihr habt keine körperliche Belastung und darum könnt ihr das auch gut einmal über längeren Zeitraum machen.
Steilspirale kennt ihr von mir, ist kein Thema.
Ist nicht geeignet, um über längeren Zeitraum Höhe kaputt zu machen.
Vor allem nicht mit den Schirmen, die wir heute haben.
Da habt ihr einfach zu viel Belastung für den Körper.
Wer da Lust und Bock hat, als Akku-Pilot, der kann das natürlich machen, aber es ist kein effektives Manöver, um für jede Höhe nötigenfalls kaputt machen zu können.
B-Stall, da nehmen wir die Bremse einfach locker am Steg in der Hand.
Jetzt, damit uns die B-Gurte nicht unabsichtlich rausrutschen, gehen wir mit den Fingern gespreizt zwischen die B-Leinen, oberhalb der Leinenschlösser.
Und packen diese so.
Symmetrisch, schön oberhalb der Leinenschlösser.
Und so können uns die B-Gurte nicht unabsichtlich entweichen.
Jetzt ist wichtig, machen wir einfach einen langsamen, aber kräftigen Klimmzug dran.
Und diesen halten wir mindestens vier bis fünf Sekunden.
Erst auf mein Kommando, Hände hoch, gehen die Hände hoch für die Ausleitung.
Und jetzt zeige ich euch, warum die Hände mit nach oben gehen müssen.
Wenn wir einfach aus dieser Position,
die B-Gurte spicken lassen, kommen wir vielleicht zusätzlich auf die Bremse.
Das wäre problematisch, denn wir lassen jetzt den B-Stall wieder gehen.
Der Schirm möchte eigentlich anfahren, ist aber noch einen Moment lang im Sackflug.
Und wenn ich dann auf die Bremse gehe, sage ich ihm eigentlich, zack, hey, geh in den Rückwärtsflug über.
Und deshalb wollen wir da auf gar keinen Fall die Gurte schneizen lassen, sondern wirklich aktiv nach oben führen.
Dann lassen wir schön aus dem B-Stall herauskommen in den Vorwärtsflug.
Bei der Einleitung lassen wir die B-Gurte, deshalb ist diese Kammgriffstellung auch so wichtig,
auch nicht gerade wieder schneizen, wenn wir am Vorpendeln sind,
weil dann würde der Schirm aus dieser Position gerade wieder anfangen und ziemlich gut beschleunigen können
und eventuell sogar zu fest beschleunigen können.
Deshalb ist es wichtig, den B-Stall oder die B-Gurte mindestens drei bis vier Sekunden,
mindestens drei bis vier Sekunden, mit der Gurte zu bewegen.
Und dann unten zu behalten.
Also runterziehen, unten behalten, sodass wir wieder zurück unter den Schirm pendeln können.
Und erst dann, wenn wir wieder druntergependelt sind, hängt er hoch für die Ausleitung.